and welcome back to Hannity this is a
Fox News Alert president Trump arriving
just moments ago at the APEC summit in
Vietnam now it's part of this very
important Asian trip and so little
coverage in the media
joining us now Fox News national
security strategist Sebastian Gorka and
former US ambassador to the UN Fox News
contributor John Bolton you know so I
had you both before he gave that speech
in South Korea which I thought was 30
miles from the DMZ Sebastian I thought
one of his finest and I thought it
reestablished America as the world power
in that arena like he did when he was in
the Middle East and almost his finest
moments and so little coverage this was
an important moment for him and this has
been an important trip so far
absolutely Sean but we've seen this all
before every trip he's had has knocked
it out of the ballpark whether it's that
incredible speech he gave in war sore
about the judeo-christian values that
our Western civilization America is
built upon whether it was going into the
heart of the Islamic world into Riyadh
and really talking tough laughs - all
those Arab leaders about how they have
to take responsibility for the
extremists and the terrorists in their
communities or whether it's standing
just miles from the DMZ and talking
about the evil that is the North Korean
Stalinist regime every trip has been
incredible and it's it's you know it's
just not interesting to the mainstream
media just as the domestic achievements
aren't interesting either whether it's
the lowest unemployment in 17 years the
25%
ikura increase in the stock market
there's reality and then there's what
the mainstream media or the fake news
industrial complex would not have you
pay attention to yeah let me get your
take on the entirety of the trip and the
importance of this trip I ambassador
Bolton I also think the particular part
where he's building and forging this
relationship with China is so key
especially in dealing with the North
Korean crisis and it is a crisis well
the big event on the trip although
obviously it's not over
the the meeting with Xi Jinping and the
discussions they had and in particular
on North Korea and as of that we don't
know how that went there was very little
comment on it just generalizations about
what was covered so we don't know
whether you Jinping resisted the tough
line I'm sure the president took said
look I'm just not going to do that or
whether possibly there's been some
movement in our direction that neither
the Chinese nor the White House think is
appropriate to discuss publicly which
wouldn't be surprising but for now I
think you'd have to say that that that
remains a big question mark I think the
visit in Japan was a big plus I thought
the speech was very Reaganesque very
tough very clear but we still need to
see what happens with the Chinese and I
must say it's going to be interesting to
see just exactly what kind of meeting he
has with Vladimir Putin in Vietnam I
don't know why the White House has been
equivocal on this I think he should sit
down with Putin I think he's got a lot
to talk to him about and I wouldn't miss
the opportunity the only think they seem
to want to cover talk to Gorka is oh
there's the president he's saying hello
to Vladimir Putin Russia Russia Russia
we've had a year of these allegations
and last Sunday Dianne Feinstein said no
evidence of collusion again smoke but no
fire again which has been pretty much
the refrain for the last year yeah it's
stunning that the Democrats of the media
didn't have a problem and Kennedy met
with crossed rifle when any other
president met with a premier of the
Soviet Union or the Russian Federation
it's just double standards if the left
didn't have double standards they
wouldn't have any standards at all so
the fact is Russia is a nuclear power it
is one of the five permanent members of
the UN Security Council it is right that
the president meet with Vladimir Putin
and talk to him as as as tough as he
talks to Xi Jinping behind closed doors
this is geopolitics short you meet with
other heads of state whether they're
good guys or not quick comment
ambassador no I think that's exactly
right and so we'll see what happens with
the Putin meeting okay thank you oh one
last question I do have a little
more time dr. korkor what are your
thoughts on this issue of Judge more
especially in light of my interview
tonight look I think that was a very
important interview I will say one thing
having met judge Moore he's not a slick
Rhyno political you know
dyed-in-the-wool operator so I think you
know his his media parents's has to have
to be judged in the light of his
background that he's not somebody who's
lived in the swamp for thirty years but
at the end of the day the truth has to
come out if anything inappropriate
happened it should be investigated but
again it's a presumption of innocence
presumption of innocence don't rush to
judgment the media has been so wrong so
often we're just gonna pursue the truth
here that's our promise